As we go to our next game,
-Stick It in My Blowhole!
Stick It in My Blowhole. -Oh.
If you're just tuning in,
moments ago,
our comedians proposed
three jizz-tastic
new PornHub
philanthropic efforts
so masturbators can fap
for the environment.
#GreenJerkers. Uh...
But since PornHub got us hornier
than a sperm whale
in Lake Titicaca with
their Save the Whales campaign,
we thought we'd kick it up
a notch by suggesting,
what if they helped
our o-ocean friends become
even more porny for whales?
Um, they get horny, too,
I assume.
So, comedians, let's help make
some whales even wetter
by naming as many lines
from undersea porns as you can
in 60 seconds. And begin.
Marcella.
You can free willy on my chest.
Points.
Wil.
I (bleep) in you on porpoise.
Points. Ross.
Two girls, one cove.
Points. Wil.
This was
no motorboating accident.
Points. Marcella.
That's not the BP oil spill.
That's Ursula squirting.
Points.
It was. Wil Wheaton.
Can I give all my points
to Marcella?
Yes, you can. Uh...
Uh, Admiral, Admiral,
the Germans have breached
the poop deck!
Points. Ross.
I want to motorboat you like
a manatee in a Florida canal.
Points.
Hey! Why are the manatees
down there?
They know
what's gonna happen! Wil.
♪ Darling, it's better
down where it's wetter ♪
Yes, points.
Uh, although that would suggest
you have crabs.
Uh...
Uh, Marcella.
Girl, are you a mermaid?
'Cause your bottom half
is fishy.
Yeah, points.
Points.
Ross Marquand.
We lost a lot of good semen
that day.
(laughs)
Points.
Goddamn it.